[Music]
[Applause]
- defensive play zero different Santa's
Dorothy found in 884 no just solids and
it noticed Alexander that one bond so
easy
the points for the rookie this Alexander
comes up long in the shop rebound
the steal by sake JoJo's Alexander to
hit him slave
seconds ago shade gorgeous Alexander
will go to midcourt Ralph I knew it was
going to go in Bradley bill didn't come
out on shade Gilda's Alexander at the
half-court line and shape he'll just
Alexander knocks it down at the
half-court line steps back mr. shott get
the rebound
fine Kobe
eight-point lead for Philadelphia
beautiful move to the goal on the finish
and the foul gilja's Alexander good till
right away this shake came ready to play
as he skies to the basket puts on the
boys blocked from behind by sheikh yonis
alexander great recovery 42 seconds to
go in the third Wow change of pace 15
for the rookie clock from 13 to 10 great
pace hesitation oh you think you gonna
stop me
Oh imma go around you off of an
offensive rebound defenses and set their
scrambled usually get a good let's go
shots blocked by Jay kill Josh Alexander
rookie against rookie stop them so far
votes away nice job of Longhorns ago
just Alexander again
[Applause]
[Music]
follow on the boat with the audits gets
a stop for three the rookie
they go down to gaalan re-take kills
this Alexander
[Music]
boring
he's in three buckets in a role for the
Clipper you see his extraordinary play
here played 40 minutes there's a steal
by guilt Islamic Center the looki will
drive the wookie will score kind of
showing us everything here tonight gets
in the passing lane end to end finishes
Clippers pushed the lead out to seven
[Music]
[Applause]
thought he had it
I mean if you want if you want to know
that Jays got some like that play we're
taught went to get it
Beverly Hills this Alexander rookie the
goal to rush long aligns used to shot
fake hesitation dribble and goes up and
finish it parallel although priceless
bro down but I won't go
[Applause]
the game was totally turned upside down
break this Lawler's long thing because
two games in a row two games in a row
it's time to rebound but can't control
her blood will come behind by shake
gilja's Alexander be able to get back he
missed the three and was able to get
back and get to block on our reporting
shooting percentage how much with Doc
Rivers raving thinking they had a shot
to get
[Applause]
Alexander Alexander Alexander Alexander
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ojas Alexander job here by the rookie
there's not too many guys in the NBA
that do that Ralph have the patience and
lift them to finish on the other side he
swamp on what they back together what up
one played all four years at UCLA really
really came on the scene as last year
again go with this Alexander whose rim
is just special look he takes the pump
takes two pumps it throws it in I mean
the jumper well Xu Clippers on the
Lakers Court in this building on Friday
night back here against San Antonio on
Saturday you can't Walker works a
distance shot is blocked inside by
Gortat terrorists explode to the basket
and throw it down lamb ball fake get the
shot blocked by guilt isalud Zander his
throw to the ball game rookie shake
yogas Alexander let's put a plate with
the young kid oh great plate gets down
the lane drive to the hoop adjusts all
they're brought to you by okay three and
a half to go Clippers by 3 plus
beautifully the long arms a shake guilt
just Alexander to him shame much longer
than Alfred Payton you see it there with
the block shot good two-way hard playing
role players that stars like the page
you plug star players into that and
they've got a chance to be an instant
contender with one of those max players
that are out there man
striction but Steve Kerr said the night
that the plan was 16 to 20 minutes see
how it goes and then we'll get two days
to rest almost a turnover but couldn't
get it Kuzma lose the basketball both
seem too jacked up no parts in the
bottle the corner Bradley for three Dan
down the guard at the scene but he is
but what I like so far is that the
clipper defense is making things happen
in offense and I think that's just the
key to this game is that the better
defense we play bears are good downhill
move it he makes great adjustments on
his drive sometimes he drew a downhill
racer here because to his left switches
hands scoops it in lefty for the route
by the three-point line and now you get
a horror scream from trades where he
could get that attacked beautiful play
by shades don't go silent and 67 53
stop lowered for veggetti an easy one a
nice feed from Harold
I love about Boston and these fans
really know basketball well that's a
nice inviolable guy from Beverly to Jake
go to Alexander going out to those loose
rebounds to give his team another chance
to edit shots at the rim
[Music]
whoever's got it and has room score and
right now for the Clippers Rubio gets a
knocked away and I love on Zillah go on
shake go to Alexander with the defensive
line you ups and downs they've been
going through a lot of downs right now
but we got the quickness of shape this
got continued to play basketball and
have fun out there
let's bounce this case Omega terrifying
so tonight versus the one thing that's
good for the NBA is you get to watch and
play in college for years and you can
give them information look
not going to get drafted you're not
going to be a first-round pick from
getting it close so you can't rest your
starters when the coach can say stay
focused but look at that when
opportunity is probably playing with
more confidence than Robinson right now
but
[Applause]
neither of those two open with all these
yellow all these other young guys huge
upside flippers in control
Sam it's over for in the early going
my himself blocked from behind by
gilja's Alexander much better with the
guy like LeBron who really likes to acid
green couldn't make it art gets the shot
blocked inside by shake gilja's
Alexander green skips it way out front
Jones as Alexander goes inside scores
and gets fouled good jump on the rookie
tied to the other and then an ISO for
shake good strong move for sago just
Alexander
he'll take it into a whole story get
fouled
Morris gets his fourth foul we get a
whistle and don't finish shade doesn't
assume he's going to get fouled or get
the whistles so continues to play a back
[ __ ] it's been their defense in
pookkalam find and Herald this two team
gets it back hajeck for the clock in the
corner three ball by shade they may not
send them they will you can't say enough
about the job they Sam Cassell has done
[Music]
walks down the lane gets fouled and go
to line the basket counts he's taking
the challenge tonight that he knows this
I might be the first team all-rookie and
that should be this position he feels
we're trying for their sixth straight
win touched a coin this yo just
Alexander do it the hole full of songs
that's what you can't teach defenders
can't catch up Tyus Jones kind of
thought he had to open a layup or was
gonna probe and [ __ ] in the first round
say gold in the state and unexcused the
money you will find I'm just thinking
there are seven other teams and the
Western come rate do not want to play
the Clippers in the first round you are
saying anybody can say and that
electrifies the crowd
[Applause]
notice Alexander the zoo BOTS and will
to finish be honest against Gallinari
[Applause]
beautiful lucky shot mom come behind is
dug in defensively
that's it keep with my that's your point
guard your rookie point guard slide over
they'll just Alexander the scoop with a
left hand to the basket and the foul
[Music]
[Applause]
Alexander going sexing a lesson for
three he gets up and down the board this
Valanciunas another turnover three
possessions three turnovers JB
Bickerstaff must be going nuts
Beverly three car bingo
[Music]
[Applause]
going coast-to-coast scoring plus one
great job using all 94 feet to the court
Jordans
[Applause]
temple will flow down
on the baseline the ball won't go
channel gets it goes this Alexander the
basket
Freddie play the 57
[Music]
and are you distance Alexandrov you
everybody went down and Beryl went up I
got the easy scores we're gonna score
there they're over the limit 100 wins
it's the law Lakers 102 Clippers 97 that
matches believe his biggest leave the
game and there's a stop
during our villages Alexander little
stopped Gallinari as escort he's not
open in the flora
alright mosquito by Douglas Alexander
and curry lets him go then I bought to
pick up a foul
vines klay Thompson Beverly on
Thompson's ball deflected by the rookie
gives this Alexander the steal the drive
and finish occur in the Warriors I'm not
concerned at all about fate Thompson
Gill juice Alexander goes right at
bucket and a finished boy a professor
bowl from the rookie just Lou Williams
other guys have to be aggressive to make
this warrior defense pay the price when
you get a mismatch this finish is tough
little body contact what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content